my oh my camila cabello is packing on
the pda with her new bow
[Music]
and camilla smooch is sending fans into
a frenzy
[Music]
here's camilla kissing austin kevich
during a day date in l.a the singer
looks super cozy and comfortable rocking
a blue floral summer dress and messy bun
gotta say it's nice to see camilla
seemingly living her best life this is
my best self a source confirms to e.t
the pair is dating they're having a
great time together and really like each
other and fans are speculating camilla's
cinderella co-star nicholas galazine may
have set the two up since austin and
nicholas follow each other on instagram
and we know they've hung out before so
for inquiring minds who want to know who
camilla's new flame is i've got you 31
year old austin is the ceo of lox club a
members only dating app and austin has
been an athlete since high school later
attending bucknell university in
pennsylvania where he played on the
school's football team
athlete entrepreneur and a guy who seems
to have made quite the impression on
camilla i feel like really in touch with
my emotions
this marks the singer's first romance
since splitting from shawn mendes in
november you don't realize
like when you're like breaking up with
someone you like think it's the right
thing you don't realize all the [ __ ]
that comes after it
at the time sean and camilla announced
they were going their separate ways
after two years of dating releasing a
joint statement on instagram quote we've
decided to end our romantic relationship
but our love for one another as humans
is stronger than ever he's like one of
my best friends he's amazing they added
we started our relationship as best
friends and will continue to be best
friends
she's been one of my best friends since
i was like 15 years old i think when you
find your person you feel and you know
that you found your person and all those
feels yeah they're both channeling them
into their music
[Music]
when you're gone is really about a
breakup and
i think in a lot of ways
it was just
me kind of processing um processing what
it feels like to be
on my own again and camilla told e.t her
song bombbomb was a therapeutic
experience
[Music]
for me my process is really cathartic
because
it's me
kind of singing anything that i think
about and feel into a microphone we'll
have to wait and see when camilla and
austin make things instagram official
but this feels like a nice soft launch
with a sweet smooch
[Music]
you